l'a2 club dorothée les trentenaires se
souviennent de ces rendez vous télévisé
pour les enfants dans l'équipe
d'animateurs fonds soit corbillé le
barbu sympathique jouer de la guitare
vingt ans plus tard il continue d'amuser
en chansons et vient de sortir un nouvel
album et il était sur la côte d'azur
aujourd'hui laurence ballon et c'est
vrai natale man l'ont rencontré françois
cormier c'est un chansonnier dans l'âme
depuis l'adolescence récré a2 club
dorothée les enfants ce fut de belles
années qu'il ne renie pas à 65 ans il a
repris sa guitare écrit compose et
chante de par le monde
[Musique]
en fait j'ai l'impression que
que le public est un peu là des chansons
faites uniquement pour les danses et des
chansons pour les pieds comme on
pourrait dire moi j'essaie de donner aux
gens des chansons qui s'adressent à
leurs yeux leurs neurones il me semble
que c'est dans ce sens là qu'il faut
aller
korbi restera un saltimbanque un peu
anarchiste comme il l'a voulu lui même
est toujours un provocateur si les profs
des écoles sont pédophiles mon bébé
c'est pour que le mna part est passée
les curés de temps en temps c'est bien
provoquer ça réveille nos consciences
sont endormis on n'ose plus rien de rien
il faut rire de tout pour ne pas se
suicider quand on voit toutes les
catastrophes qui nous arrive riom riom
toute la journée
j'avais roulé cambier balade ses
chansons aigre douce l'air de rien avec
un sourire et trois notes de ukulélé son
spectacle tiré de son dernier album est
frais et enjoué
cela plaît
[Musique]